joining us in the studio with the former
director general of Joint Force
development at strategic command air
marshall Edward Stringer is here Edward
good to have you on the program how much
did we learn and from those leaked
documents you always have to take these
things with a pinch of salt but it
certainly looks as if they're inaccurate
and it certainly looks as if they were
from the right source yes and I mean the
leak is very embarrassing
um it's one of the major leaks of of uh
of this Century that said a lot of the
information is old some of it is
doctored tactical information stales out
so if it's old it's it's not useful and
where while some of it is embarrassing
that the US is looking at what its
allies are doing as much as its enemies
that will be known to its allies it but
it's embarrassing to have it put out in
the public domain but but just in terms
of your assessment of the the urban flu
of this particular conflict the
documents suggest that the ukrainians
are perhaps not as on the front foot as
as many people had hoped and indeed
believed
yes as I said it was a couple of months
old it's before the training and latest
transfers but nevertheless I think the
fundamental picture presented uh you
know is correct and you said in your
introduction what does it show about the
the preparedness of the ukrainians to go
on the offensive and I would say there
are three things that come out yes they
were known but now you know they can't
be avoided the state of the air defenses
state of munition supply and Manpower 40
million ukrainians or 140 million
Russians
I think more but more than an
embarrassment for the government that
the information appears to have been
leaked that we do indeed have boots on
the ground that special forces
operatives have been inside Ukraine and
and will continue to be inside Ukraine
well the government will just say it it
doesn't comment um I don't think anybody
would be surprised to find out either
way the government won't comment and uh
having us director of operations been
involved in such things in the past I
know why we don't comment so I I won't
speculate now tell us then your
assessment of currently where we are in
the conflict there has been an awful lot
of talk about a potential Ukrainian
counter-offensive at some point on the
basis of what you have seen from those
leaked documents and what we are seeing
on the ground How likely do you think
that will be
well I think we we will see some form of
Ukrainian offensive I don't think it
will be uh that which might crystallize
in the average you know mind the visions
of Battle of the Bulge films and what
have you I don't think you're going to
see a frontal Onslaught by the
ukrainians but the ukrainians do need to
demonstrate that they can seize the
initiative they need to do that to
maintain the political momentum uh uh as
much as anything else but I think it
will be much more like we saw in the
Autumn of last year around her her song
and then kharkiv uh clearly after these
leagues there will have to be some
pretty extensive deception going on
um and I think you'll find ukrainians
picking and probing rather than one big
frontal assault what hope though for any
kind of counter-offensive when is you
know some ukrainians are suggesting you
know the battle for this guy is control
of their airspace might not be in their
hands for that much longer certainly not
to the same extent anyway
and that's why zelenski has been talking
about F-16 it's not because he wants one
particular type of aircraft he's
pointing out to the West that we
wouldn't fight in the way that we're
demanding the ukrainians fight and
demand the Ukrainian to take casualties
in a very land-centric
um war and we have said we'll provide
them with their defense missiles but
we're not providing them with enough and
of course they're running out of the uh
the Arsenal they had of Soviet era
surface-to-air missiles so yes I think
it's looking pretty powerless and I
would like to see the west ramp up its
production and you know guarantee those
supplies what do you think of Ben
Wallace's performance as as defense
secretary I mean so surprised here you
wonder why I'm asking that particular
question I'm sure you've got a view
um you know certainly amongst
conservative party members he is
incredibly popular I'm not so sure that
that popularity necessarily extends
quite so far into your world well I I
wouldn't want to personalize it about
the character of one individual and I
think what I know the ministerial team
has put a heck of a lot of effort into
getting around the world to to encourage
but there's a problem there isn't there
if you're encouraging everyone else to
do more you've really got to do more
yourself
um and you can put a lot of energy into
playing the wrong game and passing the
hat around all the nations scraping the
bottom of a pretty Empty Barrel is not
going to help ukrainians and I don't
think Western Europe certainly has
stepped up and realized it's got a
problem for its own defense it doesn't
have enough of a defense industrial base
it can't produce Munitions quickly
enough we need to be able to do that for
our own defense so let's put the
production capacity in place and use it
now to help Ukraine who is defeating our
number one threat for us that that is a
tricky Balancing Act to be performed
however isn't it on the one hand the
natural desire to give the ukrainians
what they want in abundance but also to
try and stop ourselves from from from
being drawn into an active conflict with
Russia ourselves
yes I think those parameters have been
pretty well set by all sides we don't
know exactly what's been discussed
between say President Biden and Xi
Jinping about limiting you know the
parameters of of this conflict but
providing more Precision weapons
allowing the ukrainians to fight
cleverly and push Russia back out of its
territory I don't think would cross any
of those major red lines that that
you're hinting at Edward sir great to
have you on the program thanks for being
with us thank you